we begin in Turkey where vegetable
edwana has won the presidential runoff
election securing a third term in office
he won more than 52 percent of the vote
in an election that has been described
as one of the most important in the
country in decades H wraps up the day's
events from Ankara
this has been one of the most important
fights in a political career spanning
three decades
a loss would have been the end of an era
a win would cement his legacy as one of
the most powerful leaders in modern day
Turkey
told a gathering of supporters to have
faith in the future
[Music]
we aren't the only winners of this
election the entire nation is turkey is
the winner today the victory belongs to
everyone it belongs to our democracy the
only losers are terrorist organizations
plotting against turkey as for the
responsibility bestowed upon us by our
nation there are no heartbreaks on our
part we aren't angry at anyone now it's
time to leave all disputes behind and
unite behind our national values and
dreams
the Run of vote was also a crucial
moment for his rival erdogan backed by
an alliance of six opposition parties
has promised to fix the economy restore
the parliamentary system and ensure
greater freedoms
opposition parties are wrapping their
minds around what went wrong they
initially thought people would vote with
their wallets that a change of heart in
the earthquake devastated areas would be
to their advantage but that didn't
happen now they need to move past anger
and frustration and perhaps consider a
complete reset of the fragile Alliance
they built for this election
political future hangs by a threat the
opposition Coalition he led May collapse
but he says the fight for change in
Turkey is far from over
I couldn't let our nation fall into
battle with another and I didn't do that
I couldn't allow our nation to suffer
from poverty and economic challenges
for your rights I have always fought and
I will continue to do so we will
continue to fight for democracy and I am
asking you to join us in our efforts
is celebrating
the man who has dominated Turkish
politics this Century faces a tough task
ahead reducing skyrocketing inflation
we're building entire cities and
improving strained relations with the
West
the governing party and its allies have
retained a parliamentary majority giving
erdoran enough support to deliver on the
promises he made during the election
campaign Ankara
opposition candidate
has thanked his supporters he said the
voter was the most unfair in years but
he promised to continue his struggle to
change what he described as an
authoritarian government Barbara anngopa
takes a look back at his career
runoff vote he'd already made history
by forcing the presidential election to
a second round and threatening to unseat
reject erdogan
softly spoken and with a calm demeanor
he's seen as the opposite of his
opponent their rivalry began 20 years
ago
in 2002
kalistarily was elected to Parliament in
the same year erdogan's Justice and
development party entered government
killisteroli took charge of his
Republican People's Party eight years
later during his 13 years at the helm he
lobbied what he called all different
colors of tequila he stood against
erdogan twice and lost twice
he survived multiple attacks including
an attempted lynching in 2019 earning
respect for his measured response to the
violence and the run-up to these
elections the opposition hoped to
capitalize on widespread frustration
with the government's slay response to
February's earthquakes and a local
currency free fall in a rare Alliance
six parties with diverse ideologies put
aside their differences to back what
they saw as the best chance of ending
erdogan's 20 years in power killister
really was their chosen candidate
but it wasn't to be and once again his
fallen short of his old rival Barbara
angerpa Al Jazeera
meanwhile Edwine supporters abroad have
been celebrating his election Victory
dozens of motorists drove through the
streets of lebanon's capital Beirut
president earned one one around 95 of
the expat votes there
and in Turkish populated neighborhoods
of Berlin crowds martyred erdogan's
election win Germany is home to the
largest Turkish diaspora and president
erdogan has a strong voter base there
and in Stockholm supporters came out to
celebrate his election Victory but
Sweden is one of the European countries
where he failed to receive the most
votes
the director of the Washington
institute's Turkish research program he
says the election results show that
erdogan is the better option for Tokyo
president erdogan had incumbency
advantages control of Institutions
information flow and media but I think
Kamal cholesterolu all LED an
uninspiring campaign president Iran
admitted maybe gambling that there were
problems for example after the
earthquake he belatedly apologized for
lackluster relief efforts and admitted
that turkey was suffering from high
inflation but he made a case
simultaneously that
he could fix those problems and I think
Kamal kalistarolu failed to make a
commission case of electorate that he
had put together a better team which you
would lead that would govern turkey
better if he was elected so in this
regard I think the campaign uninspired
the electorate the electorate said we
have problems in this country but we
still think that erdogan is the better
candidate to fix them he won comfortably
uh enough that he can say this is okay
it's sustainable so in my view it means
business as usual on the economy where
president erdogan has embraced
unorthodox economic policies he's
fighting inflation by uh trying to bring
inflate interest rates down most
economists will tell you it goes the
other way around but erdogan believes
that keeping interest rates will bring
inflation down I think he'll double down
on that unorthodox economic policy